my Village is a very beautiful one it
has a mountain full of trees or figs and
grapes
and it faces the main road to Jerusalem
this is a story about what happened here
in 1948. you are only 750 people and
everybody knows each other I came from a
big family we lived a good life we never
expect to be investigate
it was a black spot in the history that
history has been carefully concealed
purposefully distorted and in the west
largely forgotten we put our village as
an example with what they can do the
massacre in this Village was one of many
in a series of catastrophic events that
became known as the neckba when hundreds
of thousands of Palestinians were
violently displaced from their Homeland
in order to create the state of Israel
[Music]
in May of 1948 a new Jewish State Israel
was born in a bath of blood the borders
of Palestine have been changed
forcefully over time but historically
this region has been home to
Palestinians for Centuries with hundreds
of villages and thriving cities one of
them being the Central City of Jerusalem
with holy sites important to Jewish
Christian and Muslim people
by the late Ottoman Empire Palestinians
living here were overwhelmingly Muslim
with minority Christian and Jewish
native populations too but regardless of
religion Palestinians were often
referred to as Arabs people of the
arabic-speaking world despite their
distinctive culture Palestinians have
long distinguished themselves as a
householdstein where the people of
Palestine they developed a distinctive
Arabic accent they developed Regional
food Regional dress and Family Ties
but by the time World War One began
several key political forces were
competing for control of these lands
first there was a growing Arab political
movement looking for independence from
the Ottoman Empire in hopes of a unified
Arab state that would include Palestine
then there were zionists a political
group that had one main goal the
creation of a Jewish state
Zionism was a response to an
increasingly brutal climate for Jewish
people particularly in Europe and Russia
where there was a massive wave of
anti-Semitism including large-scale
attacks in the late 1800s and early
1900s
after briefly considering other areas
for a new state including Uganda and
Argentina Zionist leaders decided on
Palestine because of its connection to
early religious history but there was a
third key group with political interests
here
the British control of the region would
allow them to expand their spheres of
influence and protect trade routes to
India during World War one since both
the British and the Arab Independence
Movement wanted Palestine they decided
to go after the Ottomans together with
an important pledge through a series of
letters in 1916 an Arab leader and a
British official agreed that if Arabs
would help the British fight the
Ottomans and give the British economic
and other foreign privileges in Arab
lands in return the British would
recognize and support an independent
Arab State soon the Arabs started doing
their part in revolting against the
Ottomans making it easier for the
British to move in but the next year the
British issued a new declaration and
betrayed the Arabs
in 1917 Lord Allenby conquered the holy
land and the Jews were promised a
national home in Palestine without
consulting the native Palestinian
population the British issued what's
known as the Balfour Declaration
supporting the established men in
Palestine of a national home for the
Jewish people so instead of supporting
the idea of Palestine as part of a
unified and independent Arab State the
British pledged to help secure this land
for zionists it was a strategic move
this declaration opened up a pathway for
Britain to gain power in Palestine under
the guise that it was supporting the
self-determination of another people of
a people in Palestine who don't reside
there yet
as for palestine's majority Arab
population the Declaration referred to
them as non-jewish communities who would
be given civil and religious rights but
not political rights a few years later
after World War one ended Britain gained
control of Palestine through a mandate
that also required them to put the
Balfour plans for Jewish settlement in
motion and they did between 1922 and
1931 the Jewish population more than
doubled the migration helped the Zionist
movement gain Steam and a slogan took
off a land without people for a people
without land and it sends a message to
Western leaders that the people who had
been living in Palestine for Generations
could just be easily moved elsewhere the
idea was that those inhabitants weren't
all people with ties to that land
Palestine was of course a land with a
people in 1931 there were more than 850
000 Palestinian Arabs in the region
still the vast majority but with the
rise of Hitler and the Nazi party in
particular hate became a rallying call
Jewish flight from Europe became even
more urgent and Palestine started to see
the biggest wave of Jewish immigration
yet violence broke out rooted in
tensions over land Jewish settlers
purchased swaths of fertile land and
evicted tenant Farmers creating a crisis
of hundreds of thousands of landless
dispossessed Palestinian Arabs though
Palestinians fiercely rebelled against
both British colonial forces and Jewish
settlers they were brutally crushed by
the British they put in Palestine more
troops to repress that Rebellion than
they had stationed in India at that time
all of India these troops killed
thousands of Palestinians including many
of their leaders and the British began
training an arming Zionist militias to
suppress the Rebellion too but the
Rebellion continued so in an attempt to
prevent further Palestinian resistance
the British began to limit Jewish
immigration into Palestine
this ended up angering Zionist
extremists leading to more violence so
in 1947 after Decades of trying to
manipulate both Palestinian Arabs and
zionists to keep their control over
Palestine
Britain gave up and handed the question
of Palestine to someone else through the
United Nations also came the problem of
Palestine in recent years this small
country had been the scene of disorder
and bloodshed
they figured there is this new thing
called the United Nations
here in your lap Palestine first gift so
the United Nations has now to figure out
how do you disentangle this thing that
the British rule helped create
a un special committee proposed the land
be divided into two states a Jewish
State and an Arab state with Jerusalem
as a separate un-controlled entity it
was called the partition plan of 1947.
the plan shocked Palestinians we could
not accept the mortician plan because at
that time the population were almost two
to one but the plan proposed giving over
half the land and often the most fertile
areas to the Jewish state from a purely
pragmatic perspective
the partition plan didn't make much
sense for Palestinian Arabs that wasn't
the only problem with the plan within
this proposed area of the Jewish state
were hundreds of thousands of
Palestinian Arabs including both Muslims
and Christians who had lived there for
Generations on a moral level the idea of
making hundreds of thousands of
Palestinian Arabs minorities in their
own Homeland
seemed unjust and unfair in November
1947 the UN put the plan to a vote in
the aftermath of the Holocaust and after
lobbying from U.S leaders and zionists
the U.N voted in favor of partitions and
finally a momentous decision to
partition the holy land's ten thousand
square miles Britain announced their
mandate over Palestine would end on May
15 1948. even as Palestinians continued
to reject the un's decision to partition
the land after the politicians took
place you know in 1947 you know we
really were scared something might
happen to us by the end of 1947 zionists
had several well-developed paramilitary
forces the largest one known as the
hagana and more extremist militias like
ergon on March 10th a couple of months
before the British mandate would end the
hagana adopted what was called plan
dalit or Plan D
on paper the main goal was to gain
control of the Jewish State as laid out
in the partition plan while also
defending Jewish settlements outside of
the borders in reality that's where the
majority of these operations took place
outside of the un's proposed Jewish
State some carried out by hagana and
others by more radical militias many of
these operations focused on isolating
Jerusalem and the roads to it a set of
brutal instructions called for the
destruction of Arab Villages by setting
fire to blowing up and planting mines
especially those population centers
which were difficult to control in case
of resistance it called for the
population to be expelled outside of the
borders of the state Village is emptied
and for the occupation and control of
Arab Villages along main transportation
arteries
one of the most widely publicized
Village massacres happened here in dear
Yasin we lived in liriation which is
about four miles
west of Jerusalem 91 year old dawood
Assad was there the day of the massacre
and was 18 at the time we saw one night
that night the night before the movement
of Lights armored trucks moving around
moving moving like this so we know that
something is wrong that's why we knew
that something is going to happen to our
village
on April 9 1948 extremist Zionist forces
executing Plan D closed in on Darius
scene even though the village had made a
local piece pact with neighboring Jewish
settlements
Friday morning near Texas
my anchors they were shooting at them
and I was there loading the gun for them
and shoot them we thought about almost
two and a half hours
they found my uncle and they put him on
the wall and they shot him eight bullets
in Cold Blood
my grandmother she went in the village
to see my mother on her way she got shot
my brother Omar fell from his shoulder
to the floor with the floor was a
concrete one
dawood escaped through a trench I went
down all the way down here ladies
so over four hours walking to Jerusalem
to this day the archive of the Israeli
Army refuses to release many of the
images and intelligence reports on
Darius scene but one un report detailed
circumstances of great savagery
including women and children stripped
lined up photographed and slaughtered
roughly 100 people largely children and
the elderly were killed in the village
as for dawood he later reunited with the
group of Darius scene captives in
Jerusalem including his sister and
mother my mother says
he was shot where is your grandmother he
said you were shut and um was here
where is David where is Ahmed where is
Ismail
a dream I'm a dream about it you know
news of what happened in Darius Ian
spread quickly with far-reaching effects
the Zionist militias used it as a
propaganda tool to tell people about it
everywhere the idea was that if you
don't leave we will do to you what
happened in various scene stories came
out about women being raped about babies
being killed and induced a great deal of
fear among the Palestinian Arab
population many of them fleeing as a
result Jewish troops routed Arab forces
from the city of Haifa after taking
dariacin Zionist paramilitary groups
cleared major cities including Haifa and
Jaffa and took hundreds of smaller
Villages and towns too
hundreds of thousands of Palestinians
were forced to flee pouring into
neighboring states as refugees
Plan D became the blueprint for carrying
out the ethnic cleansing of historic
Palestine to make room for a new state
and on May 14th the day before the
British mandate ended zionists declared
this state as Israel
but the creation of Israel didn't end
the nakva neighboring Arab countries
that were overwhelmed by Palestinian
refugees immediately went to war with
Israel now United in a league of Arab
states they are insistent that the entry
of refugees into Palestine must be ended
the fighting lasted for months Arab
armies eventually lost while
Palestinians continued to be killed and
forced out throughout that time
Palestinians who fled often carried only
enough to stay away for a few weeks
hoping they'd eventually return home a
lot of them locked their doors put their
key in their pocket and then moved to
safer ground when you leave the house
and you take your key with you it's
because you're planning to go home in
the case of the Palestinians those
refugees weren't allowed to return
refugees trying to return were often
shot at Zionist paramilitary operations
also tried to prevent them from
returning Again by destroying the
villages
that act of preventing their return
compounded the nakaba so the next bit is
both the forcible displacement of
Palestinians from their homes and lands
and Country as well as preventing them
to return once the fighting was over
Palestinian Society was dismembered
crushed
more than half of the Palestinian people
became refugees stateless dispossessed
of their land
over time the state of Israel covered up
the physical evidence of an Arab
Palestine place names were often changed
from Arabic ones to Hebrew ones the
Jewish National Fund embarked on a
massive effort to plant thousands of
Acres of pine forests and recreational
areas on top of hundreds of ruined
Palestinian Villages even though these
forests have now grown into Big Pine
trees Palestinians have not forgotten
their homelands while we know that
roughly 6 000 Israelis lost their lives
in the violence of the nakba records for
Palestinian deaths weren't kept it's
estimated to be around fifteen thousand
by the end of the nakva roughly 750 000
Palestinians had been forcefully
expelled and more than 500 Villages
destroyed
though the un's partition plan allotted
Israel 56 of the land through the nakba
Israel captured 78 of the land
it was everything except what's now
known as the occupied West Bank and Gaza
Strip today that's up to at least 85
percent of the total area turning 6
million Palestinians into refugees
without a Homeland
it's why around the same time that
Israelis are celebrating independence
day Palestinians are out protesting on
May 15th holding up Keys as a symbol of
the homes they lost and the hope to
return
for them the nakba isn't just a moment
in history it's a catastrophe
that never really ended
a dream I'm a dream about it you know we
lived a good life till 1948 when we were
displaced
thank you